they're actually being journalists that
is the story is that they're actually
covering what they're supposed to be
covering and kudos to that what did you
just say the last one minute okay
honestly like what did you just say
you're saying that the journalists are
actually doing their job and they're
covered these journalists don't do their
jobs okay
no no we've but but no no Adam when
somebody hasn't been doing their jobs
for the last 10 years suddenly starts
doing their job it's not because
suddenly they got inspired to say let's
become journalists today no there has to
be a motive why on suddenly they became
journalists all aligned simultaneously
together